SPEAKER: Data is often
scattered in many places.
You may store customer
tables in BigQuery,
while your sales tables
live in Cloud SQL.
Nonetheless, it
is important to be
able to join these
tables together
when performing analysis.
Cloud SQL Federation
from BigQuery
enables you to
analyze data residing
in Cloud SQL in real time,
without copying or moving data.
It supports both MySQL
and Postgres instances,
and Cloud SQL.
After an initial
one-time setup, you
can write queries referencing
connected Cloud SQL
tables using a special SQL
function called External Query.
Let's walk through the steps
to complete the initial setup,
and then run an example query.
Step 1.
Enable the BigQuery
connection service.
Start in the Cloud
console, and select
the project that includes
the Cloud SQL instance
that you want to query.
If you would like to start
with the same Cloud SQL
instance we are using
in this Quick Start,
you may pause the video and
first follow the codelab linked
in the description below.
In this project, you will need
to have both the BigQuery admin
role and the Cloud SQL editor
or Cloud SQL admin role.
Use the left-hand menu to
click on APIs and Services.
Click Enable APIs and Services.
And then search for
BigQuery connection API.
Click to enable.
Step 2.
Configure public IP connectivity
for your Cloud SQL instance.
Use the search bar to
navigate to Cloud SQL.
Click the instance name
to open its details page.
Select the connections tab.
Make sure the public
IP checkbox is marked.
While public IP connectivity
is not as secure as private IP
only, your instance
will remain inaccessible
from the public internet,
because you have not
provided an authorized address.
However, this will make
it possible to connect
to your instance from BigQuery.
Click Save, if you made changes.
Step 3.
Set up the Cloud SQL database
connection in BigQuery.
Use the search bar to
navigate to BigQuery.
Click Add Data.
And select External Data Source.
Now you'll provide the
details needed to establish
the connection resource.
Choose your database
type-- in this case, MySQL.
Give the connection ID and name.
You will use this identifier
when you are referencing
the resource from a query.
The location you choose must be
compatible with your Cloud SQL
region and your intended
use within BigQuery.
Since our Cloud SQL database
is located in US Central one,
we will need to use the
US multi region location.
More information on
location compatibility
is linked in the
description below.
Enter the full name of
the Cloud SQL instance
in the format of project ID,
colon, location ID, colon,
instance ID.
You can find the instance ID on
the details page of the Cloud
SQL instance you want to query.
For database name, enter
the name of the database.
Then enter the username and
password for the database.
Note-- if these same
user credentials are
valid for other databases in the
particular Cloud SQL instance,
the connection will
also allow queries
over those additional databases
through the same connection
resource.
Click Create Connection.
You'll see the connection
populate in the left-hand nav.
Step 4.
Grant permissions
to connection users.
Select the connection in the
left-hand nav and click Share
Connection.
Enter the user's address and
select BigQuery Connection
User, which gives
the user the ability
to query with the connection.
Alternatively, you
can give a user
the role BigQuery
connection admin,
which allows them to create,
manage, and share connections,
in addition to using
them in queries.
Now that we've completed
the initial setup,
let's see how to write
queries over tables
in the connected database.
Our first query joins the
employees and salaries tables,
both in the Cloud SQL database,
to analyze the average salary
by year of hire.
Querying over the
external connection
requires the external
query function.
The syntax of this function
requires the connection ID,
which you can find by
selecting the connection
and looking in the details.
Next is a string of the query
in the external databases SQL
dialect.
Note that when querying
a Cloud SQL connection,
BigQuery can not predict the
amount of data to be processed.
You will only know after you run
your query, when you hit Run.
The query is executed in the
external database in Cloud SQL.
Next, let's see an example
of joining a BigQuery
table with a table in
your Cloud SQL database.
We have taken a snapshot
of the salaries table
and loaded it into
BigQuery's, so
that we can show joining data
across BigQuery and Cloud SQL
resources.
The example query
includes three parts.
External query is used to
select the employee number
and hire date fields from the
Cloud SQL employees table.
Then, the results are
joined by employee number
with the salaries table
which is located in BigQuery.
Finally, the query
calculates the average salary
for employees in each hire year.
Click Run.
And after the query completes,
you'll see the same results.
The cost of your queries
will follow standard BigQuery
pricing, either on demand,
based on the amount of data
processed, or as part
of a flat rate model
if that is applicable
to your organization.
You've just seen how to set
up a Cloud SQL connection
and query the connection using
the external query function.
For more information
on Federated queries
with Cloud SQL, please
navigate to the documentation
linked below.
Happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]